on reste à l'international mais on
change de région si vous le voulez bien
recep tayyip erdogan le président turc
et têtière chiffres l'admirent poutine à
sotchi en russie
c'est leur septième rencontre depuis le
début de l'année donc ces deux là ils
s'entendent bien et ils sont d'ailleurs
parvenus à un accord
les turcs donc le 9 octobre ont pénétré
en syrie pour essayer de mettre hors
d'état de nuire les kurdes de syrie
eh bien les turcs ont accepté de ne pas
rester en syrie et en échange
poutine s'est engagé les kurdes ne
resteront pas non plus dans cette zone
qui est à la frontière turque
et c'est son allié bachar el-assad qui
va s'en assurer bref tout le monde est
content en tout cas le président turc
lui l'est sur lénine traquent le guide
in the pool françois pauly le 6 octobre
dernier les américains se sont retirés
de syrie ils ont retiré leurs troupes
mais ils ont aussi retiré
apparemment leur influence leur volonté
de peser dans la région et c'est
extraordinaire c'est vraiment poutine le
maître du jeu là avec ses deux alliés
bachar el-assad en syrie et les iraniens
nous dit c'est tout le monde est content
sauf les kurdes mieux entendus voilà et
j'ai cru comprendre que il avait voilà
qu'on les troupes américaines sont
partis les kurdes qui était sur place
avaient hué les soldats américains donc
nous dit si on se rend pas compte tout
ça à paris moi j'ai beaucoup lu ce qu'a
écrit patrice franceschi sur la question
kurde c'est très difficile de
l'extérieur de donner des leçons de
morale comme on a un petit peu le
tendance à le faire surtout quand on va
pas se secourir les gens sur le terrain
comme en attendant un qui peut le faire
en france enfin ce qui ressort de cette
affaire c'est vraiment que poutine agit
enfin coup de maître et que d'après ce
que j'ai cru comprendre
trump est apparu comme quelqu'un de
complètement erratiques dans son
comportement il poursuit la politique de
retrait d'obama mais que le maître du
jeu ces petits parce que ils jouent
toutes les cartes en même temps et il
gagne à chaque fois c'est quand même
incroyable surtout renommant de
situation que la sortie est
traditionnellement c'était les
américains qui intervenait partout
aujourd'hui ils retirent leurs troupes
et là le pays qui étend son influence et
la russie alors d'abord ça correspond à
une volonté très affirmée des états unis
de cesser d'être les gendarmes du monde
commence avec obama absolument donc
trump et accentue cette cette ligne là
et puis aussi en dénonçant
multilatéralisme et en fait c'est un
c'est ce qui se passe en syrie est un
bon exemple de la nouvelle donne
géopolitique ou en fait on avait des
puissances dominantes qui prétendait
effectivement régner sur un certain
nombre de pays aujourd'hui elle se elle
se retire et qu'est ce qu'on voit
finalement pointé et s'affirmer c'est
l'activisme de puissance régionale et la
russie en est un parfait exemple
donc là elle profite en effet de la
division des alliés parce que cette
invasion turque a évidemment fait bondir
les alliés européens et tout camp
occidental les européens se retourner
contre les états unis en leur reprochant
d'avoir laissé tomber les kurdes
donc ça ça bénéficie aux intérêts russes
poutine est ravie parce que du coup
l'otan s'en trouve affaibli et puis en
plus ça éloigne la turquie de son allié
américain donc du coup ça laisse le
champ libre à la russie est ce qu est ce
qui est vraiment très intéressant c'est
évidemment de voir combien c'est
puissant slide donc la russie profitent
du désengagement américain et la russie
qui jusque-là n'intervenait pas beaucoup
elle observer ce qui se passait là elle
le moscou n'a pas une vraie stratégie
c'est plutôt une tactique et mais elle
sait mieux que quiconque ça visiblement
ça c'est vrai je vous rejoins profiter
de la place qui est laissée vacante par
les états unis
ça c'est clair absolument elle sait très
bien le faire et d'ailleurs elle jette
aussi ses filets cette russie ailleurs
dans d'autres endroits en afrique il
n'ya pas longtemps si les terres
poutine et en arabie saoudite pour
resserrer ses liens et notamment ses
sondes accords pétroliers en afghanistan
la russie a aussi pointé son nez dans
les négociations qui avaient été
abandonnés par les américains en
septembre avant d'être reprise donc on
voit bien que c'est vraiment un pays est
évidemment c'est poutine derrière qui
sait parfaitement le faire profiter de
ces zones-là laissé libre c'est dans ce
sens que effectivement ces
problématiques
est-ce que c'est inquiétant si vu comme
elle que la russie redevienne une grande
puissance diplomate que je trouve ce que
je trouve inquiétant c'est que justement
la russie a effectivement que poutine
m'apparaissent nous apparaissent
maintenant comme l'homme raisonnable
non non non il apparaît probable que ces
interventions monde
et et quelques pas dans ce dossier sont
opérationnels on rationne nationale
alors ça je l'aurais pas prévu voyez je
n'aurais pas pensé qu'un jeu long sur
les insectes surtout qui rafle la mise
je trouve que c'est un coup un coup de
matt mission était oui je présenterai
aujourd'hui on est plus rassuré parce
que ces actions cette décision qu'on
voit bien que 5,2 de trump donc voilà ça
va bien je n'ai pas la liberté de
président a toujours pas d'accord
et pourtant il se fait passer pour le
grand passage obligatoire de la zone
ça c'est magnifique oui le tout en cinq
joueurs sur internet est passé pour le
groupe un acteur de poids de l'armée et
s'entraîne comme effectivement larrons
en foire après c'est taper dessus il ya
un nombre de guerre qui sous les olé
entre la turquie et les russes
elle fut considérable et encore en 2015
ont été abattus donc il ya quelques
jours fait la realpolitik les rues sont
au queens est quand même quand le un
moment donné quand ankara justement se
lançait froidement dans sa danse on
attaque à un moment donné les russes ont
quand même dit il faut y aller mais il
faut voir c'est à dire que déstabiliser
sachs savait exactement parce que c'est
quand même damas qui est en ligne de
mire et le renforcer lui dans quelque
sorte le jeu donc en fait ils ont fait
un truc formidable les russes ils ont
réussi à la fois à la fois à se
positionner en médiateur entre les uns
et les autres en l'espèce on entre parce
qu'il parlait aux kurdes aussi et les
turcs et sceller cette espèce d'accord
qui a l'air d'être un accord de paix
pour le compte de tiers si je puis dire
et tout ça après avoir quand même
ronchonner
publiquement qu'il fallait il fallait y
aller mollo et le tout après que les
américains aient sollicité cette trêve
donc c'est quand même assez assez drôle
enfin étonnant cette espèce
d'enchevêtrement de tempo 1
plus symboliquement c'est intéressant la
crimée est un axe est une expression qui
appartenait l' empire ottoman et voilà
quand même très fort bien quand même un
antagonisme actuels sont écroués il
arrive à manipuler à manoeuvrer un pays
qui est quand même qui a été un ennemi
il a réussi à scorer ya eu cette
histoire d'avion air deviennent avait dû
envoyer une lettre d' excuses pour
renouer les liens avec bottines en 2015
l'avion qui avait été abattu par les
turcs par les turcs
on allait envoyer une lettre d' excuses
donc oui c'est intéressant aussi c'est
le pardon c'est le contraste entre cette
puissance diplomatique claire et la
puissance économique je lisais je ne
m'en souvenais plat mais le pib de la
russie est inférieur a servi de l'italie
c'est qu'on observe un découplage en
fait dans la domination aujourd'hui des
licences des états c'est à dire que
auparavant et les puissances dominantes
elle est l'associé la puissance
économique la puissance militaire et
puis aussi la puissance de la capacité
de rallier
l'adhésion volontaire de pays à leur
valeur à leurs modèles aujourd'hui ça
n'est plus le cas vous avez des
puissances comme la chine par exemple
qui du moins officiellement ne prétend
pas avoir une volonté de projection
politique mais simplement s'en tenir à
l'économie officiellement je dis bien et
militaires bon à la mais bon
officiellement c'est le cas les états
unis donc là aussi sont un petit peu
sont vraiment sur le retrait
donc c'est aussi ça que ça ça représente
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment une nouvelle
donne qui est assez passionnante et sont
une illustration
et quant à ce genre de manoeuvres
s'agissant de la russie ça comment
dirais je
ça remplit ça remplissait ses objectifs
de grandeur faut pas oublier que la
russie est pétri et de toujours depuis
toujours de cette perspective de
s'étendre et vers les mers enfin bref il
y avait une union soviétique et tout ça
est une tradition d'expansion qui n'a
pas de raison de s'éteindre
et c'est très anciens 13 ans pour ton
petit nas a vraiment chevillée au corps
il a très mal du tout oui c'est vraiment
et la turquie là ils sont tous derrière
de gand il y avait en moyenne sur une
quasi unanimité nationale
il était encore garde l'a perdu mais là
son mouvement son attaque contre les
kurdes
il a quand même reçu les autres partis
voilà et ça c'est le nationalisme c'est
la force du nationalisme alors nos
internautes se réjouissent que poutine
est permis l'arrêt tombe le tilt
définitif même si il faut y a pas encore
eu de 2,2 d'arrêt officielle du conflit
de l'offensive turque
faut-il félicité poutine pour l'arrêt de
l'offensive turque c'est oui à 71% chez
nos internautes je vous rappelle que
vous votez sur twitter et de
commentaires celui de citoyen payeur
erdogan sait qu'il perdra contre les
américains ils se raccrochent à celui
qu'il croit être son allié alors qu'il
perdra contre les américains oui encore
que les américains restent très présents
militairement en turquie et ils ont
besoin des basses turquie est un
notamment pour
leur armement qui est une espèce de deux
postes avancés des états unis dans la
région
et puis philippe qui lui dit poutine a
toujours été clair sur ses objectifs
redonner une zone d'influencé à la
grande russie en fait ce qui peut
peut-être expliquer ce paradoxe dire que
la russie soit à la fois économiquement
un presque 1 1 est très puissant c'est
peut-être parce que poutine n'a pas peur
il n'a pas peur de salir les mains
je veux dire quand il dit la crimée
c'est à moi vous voulez pas que je
récupère cette ce territoire je m'en
fous l'onu est content je le fais quand
même pas peur d'envoyer ses soldats
faire la guerre pas peur d'apparaître
comme un non démocrates pas peur de son
opinion publique parce que toute façon
ceux qui protestent
on les met hors d'état de de s'exprimer
tout ça est un peu inquiétant peut-être
paul françois paoli seul ait ce retour
de la force qui n'ait pas peur de nous
c'est très compréhensible vu ce qu'on
représente sur un plan sur le plan
militaire sur le plan de l'agressivité
moi j'habite emblématique l'europe ne
fait rien voilà je pense que erdogan et
poutine ce qu'ils ont en commun c'est le
mépris un certain mépris de l'occident
un certain mépris de l'occident
hardinghen ces déclarations sont
absolument
elles sont d'ailleurs pénible très racée
insupportable et poutine
c'est je crois que c'est quelqu'un qui a
été déchue terriblement par l'europe et
je sais bien que macron a changé sa
ligne et sa manière de voir et de faire
avec lui je pense qu'il était temps
mais vous voyez 70% aux internautes
votent pour lui donc c'est quelqu'un qui
a un charisme politique qui est
indiscutable même si on n'est pas
d'accord avec son parce que ce qu'il
fait
comment arrive-t-il alors que
effectivement la russie et dans dans un
tel état comment arrive-t-il à imposer
sa volonté à l'extérieur c'est quand
même quelque chose d'impressionnant je
pense que la donne et américaine est
fondamental il y arrive parce que le
champ il est laissé libre en fin de vie
hier il en profite
il n'a pas particulièrement cherché sa
voie windows en commun
à vendre un avant-centre une équipe de
football qui marque en 2015 en ayant en
appuyant régime de bachar el assad
ils en profitent maintenant il sait
toujours entre les annonces faites par
tweet du retrait américain est bon la
sphère d'ankara puil cet accord dit
juste 15 jours
franchement le 6 octobre les turcs
pénétrant suivie le 9 octobre
et oui cette fille on est le 22 et 23
voyez en quinze jours c'est quand même
de la belle ouvrage du point de vue du
fils les lotos que même ça devrait
d'ailleurs baba j'en ai pour rien entre
les deux sujets que nous avions
aujourd'hui je crois savoir que le jeudi
là le jeudi le conseil européen où on
ont fignolé encore ce fameux accord a
présenté attentes et présenté en vue du
rexy c'était quand même un concept dédié
à la faire à l'attack d'ankara je n'ai
pas le souvenir qu'on en ait retenu
grand chose à la vérité de ce qu'on
aurait dit le conseil de l'europe à ce
sujet temps nous étions arrivés à cette
histoire de d'accord est ce qu il breake
site est ce qu'ils allaient être
terminées présentable etc tout est
absorbé par ce sujet sachez d'accord on
revient en france si vous le voulez bien
avec des nouvelles de françois baroin le
président de l'association des maires de
france s'était fait très discret ces
derniers temps au malawi un suggère un
peu moins dramatique sort doté toutes
les vidéos ça mais deux invités en
joueurs on va on va voir pourquoi alors
françois baroin d'autres noms dont on
n'entendait plus beaucoup de parler
vient d'annoncer qu'il allait faire son
entrée au comité stratégique des
républicains alors vous allez me dire
que ça vous ne rêvez pas forcément la
nuit sauf que le nouveau président des
républicains
c'est christian jacob un chiraquien qui
est un proche depuis toujours de
françois baroin chiraquien comme lui et
que